oh my god it actually work Wonder Woman
is out in theaters now and fans and
critics both like it I already have my
non-spoiler review of this up so if you
haven't seen the film and you don't want
to be spoiled I'm about to get into
spoilers check out that review
you've been warned let's continue can we
just take a minute and actually breathe
for a second and realize how far we've
come in regards to comic book
adaptations to the big screen starring
women in 1984 we had Supergirl that was
trash in 2004 we had Catwoman
that was real trash and in 2005 we had
electra which was just really bad i mean
this is kind of incredible but it's yeah
this is like history this is awesome
Wonder Woman genuinely was everything I
wanted out of a Wonder Woman movie and
more because not only did we get a lot
of really badass action sequences like
when she flips that tank over when she
codes like headfirst into a tank or when
they do the shield trick and she
launches into the air and destroys the
entire top of that building they didn't
even have to show the dead body of the
sniper that building you're just like
yeah that guy's fucked that opening
action sequence onthe mascara was so
incredible and really emotional Robin
Wright's character who was the primary
mentor of Diana dies and so that's a big
moment for her but along with all of
that badass action even more importantly
patty Jenkins as the director infused
quite a bit of emotion into this film
this is a movie that isn't just about
action sequences in fact there are a
long portions of this movie where nobody
does anything of an action standpoint
because the film takes a lot of time to
set up these characters as realistic
people as human beings and it finds the
humor in some of the weirder things
about Diana's upbringing like how she
was brought to life by Zeus and molded
from clay
and one of my favorite scenes in the
movie on the boat where Diana and Steve
Trevor pollute like Chris Pine are
talking about reproductive biology and
sex and whether or not it's normal to
physically sleep next to someone that
you're not with it's smaller moments
like that in this movie that make it so
much better than it could have been
because yeah you could just had a
two-hour movie of Wonder Woman punching
people and sure would have been visually
entertaining but you would have left not
giving a shit I mean and that's what I
didn't want going in I was so afraid it
was just going to be a really badass
movie and nothing else this film has so
much more emotion than I expected the
theme that actually did make me come
really close to tearing up is near the
end where Steve is telling Diana how he
really feels right before he kills
himself on that plane destroying all
that poison gas and then later you get
to hear what he actually said and he
gives her that watch it's just really
really good storytelling and really good
writing and acting on both of their
parts when I saw this a couple weeks ago
before had read a single interview with
patty Jenkins
I knew she must have loved Richard
Donner's Superman because there's a lot
of references to it and there's a very
similar feel and sure enough she has
come out and said that she was heavily
inspired by it as a young girl and so
it's really cool to see that because
there's there's even like scene homage
is to it there's that moment where Diana
saves Steve in that alleyway by
deflecting one of the bullets that is
very much so like this moment in the
first Superman
[Music]
or like when diana is holding her shield
and her sword trying to get through that
revolving door very much so like
Christopher Reeves portrayal of Clark
Kent in the first Superman where he gets
stuck in the revolving door but it's
also a complete lack of brooding angst
or cynicism in the character of Diana
she's very hopeful she's full of joy you
could say naive and she definitely is
but that's the characters journey she
starts very naive and at the end of this
movie you can see that she's come to a
higher level of understanding about what
the world's really like and that's why
her character is so great in the film
because they don't just set her up as
this perfect person who can kill
everybody in the blink of an eye with no
problems and she has nothing to learn
she grows so much in this film that I
began to care for that character quite a
bit and it makes me more excited for
movies like Justice League just because
she's in it they also got something so
right and something that I was honestly
concerned about I'm always afraid
whenever I hear about how a movie is the
film that we need right now this film
can change the world it's the movie that
we need right now I'm always so
concerned when I hear that because I'm
afraid about politics and movies the
assertion of one's own beliefs in movies
and gracefully none of that exists here
there's a scene where it really could
have gone that way where Steve Trevor
says you can't cross this barrier okay
that's no-man's land it means no man can
cross it she could have turned to the
camera and been like well I'm not a man
so you know I'm just gonna cross it okay
bye but there's nothing like that she
just goes it's what I have to do and she
does it there isn't that scene where
patty Jenkins and the writer make men
feel inferior thusly empowering women
because that's not how you should do it
because then it's still about men female
empowerment is all about women because I
never watched the first Superman movie
thinking man I feel so empowered because
I'm a guy right now because Superman
isn't just for men and the same with
Wonder Woman yes a lot of women are
going to love this movie but
so should men she's not just a hero for
girls just as Superman isn't just a hero
for boys and they got that so right in
this movie and that was such a pleasure
to see now obviously the biggest spoiler
is that Sir Patrick is actually Ares and
hiding this really could have gone south
because there's a lot of CG in this
finale which is to be expected it's
Wonder Woman she is not a normal person
as I said in my non-spoiler review she
is a superhero and so there's going to
be CG but there's a lot of it gratefully
because the film took so much time to
set up the characters it didn't bother
me because I was invested and I fell for
her when she was trapped in that metal
when Ares was holding her down and she
screamed no you know when Steve died I
was like I really felt that moment it
wasn't just you know some cheesy no like
Revenge of the Sith it actually I felt
like I was watching a real character
dealing with something that was truly
hurting her and affecting her and it
made me care and I did I did cheer up a
little bit I won't lie the film
succeeded on just about every single
level my least favorite thing about the
film as I said in my non-spoiler review
is the villains can be a little hammy it
was kind of stupid that the Danny Huston
character was basically just a red
herring the whole time and when you
watch the movie a second time it makes
you really not give a shit about any of
his scenes beyond that I really like
this movie and I hope you guys did too
thank you so much as always for watching
guys if you liked this you can click
right here and get steppen eyes
[Music]